alors quel est votre question que
largement défloré oui vu le mal que j'ai
à me caser il faut pas jamin j'ai vu le
mal que j'ai à me caser ça me fait très
peur
j'hésite énormément plus c'est vrai
qu'on est médiatisé donc je me dis est
ce que c'est la bonne sans casser
mauvais pas d'emblée michael jackson
bien sûr il médiatisé j'ai pas dit ça
donc est-ce que je dois me résoudre ce
sera l un peu la dernière chance pour
moi mais ce que je dois me résoudre à
m'inscrire sur un site de rencontres j'y
connais rien ça me fait peur donc j'ai
besoin de votre avis à tout ça d'accord
alors dépendre libellé du message bas
ses jokers
[Rires]
c'est alors qu'ils pensent que c'est une
bonne idée
ah oui oui j'ai eu très très peur parce
que oui alors je n'en avais demandé à
l'inviter à c'est nous c'est ce que vaut
évidemment vous n'avez pas besoin
d'aller sur un site au rendez-vous quand
c'est alors qu'est ce qui alors qu'est
ce qui vous a motivé à ce qu'il faut où
il faut conseiller madame mais j'avais
pas beaucoup de temps devant moi je
travaille je travaillais beaucoup à
l'étranger avec mon travail et il
fallait que voilà quand je rentre et on
avait beaucoup aimé mon travail
non non j'ai trouvé elle est troublée
vous là parce que je pars de mon amour
voilà les noms n'ont du coup je
voyageais beaucoup et quand je rentrais
en france je voyais ma famille et mes
amis et je n'avais pas d'occasions de
rencontrer de nouvelles têtes nouvelles
personnes du coup je me suis mis sur un
site de rencontres et voilà toujours
absolument
[Applaudissements]
alors donc donc vous donc vous
encourager daniel moreau je me dis que
c'est ainsi nous voyez ça ne vous
emballez pas quand même trop hein donc
se profile à droite et les cas leur le
profit je ne sais pas c'est là le
problème c'est que ça fasse sérieuses et
voilà je suis un vieux cherche
partenaires
on a le droit d'être faut alors
kikikikiii pour encore quand ce alors qu
attendent pour d'abord pour le libellé
de la non c'est non métier pour pourrait
pour que pour que daniel s'inscrivant
ainsi d'un certain ces deux rencontres
et saufs kayak s'y connaît non mais un
site de rencontre mais moi je dis que
franchement là où tu en es
vas-y fond des âmes mais tout les gens
de ton côté tu fais taper tous les
produits
et puis voilà ça t'a posé comme c'est
comme dans les bronzés oublie qu aucune
chance et font ce malentendu
non mais moi je suis allergique vous
pensez que c'est une mauvaise idée ah
oui moi j'ai très peur pour daniel moi
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un sur 36 15
aligne par minitel 36 15
lui l'a longtemps oui j'ai très peur
pour vous alors parce que vous êtes
fragile et vous allez tomber sur des
pervers qui vous brisez et comme je vous
connais très sensible j'ai passé j'ai pu
pour ça dit elle même beaucoup daniel
j'ai peur qu'elle rencontre des hommes
qui vont essayer d'avoir une relation
sexuelle avec elle parce que c'est un
défi daniel monde
j'ai conscience daniel moreau julie vont
très mal non allez voir donc gilles sidi
j'ai couché avec daniel moreau ça veut
dire que daniel moreau a touché aussi
rue moret réjasse est bien d'accord mais
si c'est pour voir on va dans des sites
sérieux sans pour cela elle sait qu'ils
ont pour se lève
merci ceux qui n'avaient pas vous les
publics
[Rires]
c'est assez mitigé
alors il faudrait choisir une photo
parce qu'il faut enfin qu'il faut à huy
est-ce que je peux prendre une photo de
son bilan alors je rassure un profil
normalement on doit on doit mentir au
minimum oui que non mais attendez on a
des photos pour vous l'avez des
chouettes photos
alors on a on a vu cette photo alors je
vous déconseille
c'est là ça donne un peu trop la couleur
quand même selaçao d un film d'horreur
qui la poussent mais non là d'où est
bien mais quand même noter que vous êtes
en noir et blanc
c'est quand même donné une indication
je vais des entrées muret rêve sur la
5ème et la seule de ses douze si votre
maman oui
non mais ça on va éviter ça va éviter l
arrière matt et jimmy c'est peut-être ça
comité non à léon tard sur la deux non
la royalty côté sushi oui la mission de
on dirait décret s'applique à 333.33
ambiance donc gallichan n'est pas comme
ça au quotidien n'ont pas le profil
maintenant pour le profil pour le profil
est ce que c'est le profil c'est le
premier profil c'est parce qu'on va
acheter quand même alors
au monde derrière des brouillages
cherche un homme costaud évolué avec de
l'humour et de la tendresse je veux
partager des soirées théâtre télé des
vacances à royan d'être sur le cd + et
vivait alors ça veut la fin veut lui
pourquoi pas mais ça s'est échauffé vous
adore c'est un montant bien les plus moi
c'était jean yanne savez le côté même
une même torse mais très franchement
donne envie là depuis qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé j'ai vous voit le sondage de
son arrière alors dit je pense qu'il a
fait monter les violons les gens vous
encourage
écoutez on va suivre ça de près ouais
vous mais s'est fait un cadeau qu'un
médecin oui on ne vous inquiétez pas
cessé de tirer de tout à fait gaffe
quand même parce que m'est arrivé un
truc ont eu lieu sur un site comme ça
quand j'habitais un peu loin en amérique
je pensais que c'était illégaux dans la
région que s'afficher le profil en fait
c'est au labeur de word
donc attention c'est les plantes est
géolocalisé à moi j'avais une gare tgv
partout donc gpmm est arrivé en france
je n'avais pas savoir c'est ça voilà
qu'à filer votre décision évidemment
parce que maintenant j'ai peur mais
c'est vrai que l'expérience de centimes
alors il est vrai bien quand même
si vous étiez déjà médiatique au paddock
non mais sur le gt journaliste sportive
donc oui sur le sport il me connaissait
pas elle a très bien dormi aussi fava
lama fument alors oui ou non si oui ou
non je peux signer vous allez les
risques
[Applaudissements]